in italy we have a famous song
in case the world is falling down i go
back a little bit to not get hurt but
what if a nuclear bomb were to fall in
the city where i live in tuscany which
is prato this is something i ask myself
with a bit of paranoia how much further
back am i supposed to go to ensure that
i don't vaporize instantly after all the
dogma of this era seems to be never say
never pandemics wars italy out of the
world cup meanwhile everyone wants to
build their own bunker yep there are
companies that are specialized in this
now you know in switzerland just to say
since 1963
it is mandatory by law to provide every
building with a bomb shelter while in
italy we don't have any regulatory plan
providing for the construction of
bunkers at least in theory but hey
what's the deal we can always use our
sellers as bunkers after getting all the
permissions of course
if you had a thousand years the door is
now closing guys however since a bunker
costs several tons of thousands of
dollars and since i'm not paid enough if
an atomic bomb were to follow my little
town i would have no choice but to run
away hopefully with a fast car luckily
for me a simulator called nuke map
created by historian alex wallerstein
has been around for several years now
showing the range of action and
destruction of an atomic device
[Music]
we'll take a look at it but before i
give you an unjustified anxiety i wanted
to ask myself what are the nations that
possess the warheads capable to unleash
the atomic holocaust
these are not so many on the one hand
you have the classic ones united states
russia france the united kingdom china
which are all signatories of the treaty
on the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons but on the other hand you have
four countries that are not yet members
of such agreement namely india pakistan
north korea and israel even if the
latter is only unofficially part of it
apart from a couple of them they all
seem to be nice and quiet but surprise
we italians still have nuclear warheads
at our disposal oh right they are not
really ours according to the nato
nuclear sharing plan it has been decided
to involve in the nuclear warfare also
some non-nuclear countries of the
alliance like us italians mostly for
shared strategies and planning but also
for the supply of warheads so much
non-proliferation
i can smell it the u.s and who otherwise
have land italy belgium germany the
netherlands and turkey their own toys
that of course they cannot use at their
own pleasure so did you hear me don't
play with those gifts the bombs are
guarded by u.s soldiers and without us
codes they can't be used but in case of
war we still have to prove that we're
capable of using them and we cannot
afford to fall off the wagon according
to a report by analyst hans christensen
from the nature resources defense
council in 2005 in italy there were 90
warheads 50 in the base of aviano and 40
in the base of geditory today the
estimates point a total of 40 warheads
but it seems also that there's a real
secret bilateral agreement between our
country and the u.s called stone x which
would provide for a further deployment
of american nuclear weapons on our
territory making an estimates of the
warheads currently in circulation is a
bit complicated but one thing is certain
russia and the united states share about
90 percent of the world's nuclear
weapons according to the federation of
american scientists in the first part of
2022 the estimated number of warheads
around the world was 12
700 of these except those being
dismantled the actual warheads for
military use are
9400 but only 3700
are the ones currently deployed and
operational 2000 of these even in state
of alert ready for immediate use russia
would be in the first place with
5977 warheads followed by the united
states with 5428
but if we take into account only the
deployed warheads the united states
would have a slight advantage 1744
against 1588.
just to realize the difference in level
with the rest of the world in third
place we find china which boasts only
350 warheads while north korea only has
20 warheads yes dr kim you have to eat
more uranium we should go easy on good
old kim apparently he has some very
dangerous new toys now in fact
pyongyang's latest tests have glorified
the power of the new wazon 17 missiles
capable of reaching american and
european soil
these images from north korean state
media show the country launching its
most powerful missile yet
inside the isolated and secretive
country celebration
of course so far they haven't gone
beyond japan a coincidence one might say
north korea is provoking the
international community even as it's
responding to russia's invasion of
ukraine
we absolutely cannot tolerate this okie
dokie potentially kim could hit us right
now if he wants what about the others
france would have no problem at all to
hit their beloved cousins from italy and
since in the past they have already
given us their warheads i would be
careful also usa and uk may have no
problem to send us their missiles and
neither russia pakistan and india
perhaps wouldn't make it both the
pakistani shaheen and the indian agni
have a more limited range after all they
only care about destroying each other
and maybe hitting china china for its
part with its d41 missiles and
especially with the new hypersonic
models has all the requirements to be a
good candidate to destroy my town in
tuscany come on bring it on you and what
are me
[Music]
they sound convincing so what would
happen if a nuclear warhead fell right
here in this exact spot where i live
let's say for example a russian warhead
hits the ground right here purely random
example first of all according to the
experts of the bulletin of the atomic
scientists it's also to be believed that
the nuclear warheads today at the
disposal of the russians have a charge
of 100 kilotons which to be clear would
be equivalent to 800 000 tons of
dynamite those of hiroshima and nagasaki
were between 15 and 20 kilotons
intercepting a nuclear intercontinental
ballistic missile is technically
possible but very difficult and
unpredictable given the parabolic
trajectory of the icbm the most basic
system is basically just shooting a
missile at a missile yes during the cold
war that's what russians and americans
called anti-ballistic missile but we
never had the honor to experiment the
effectiveness of such tactics so far
hiroshima and nagasaki were the only two
history cases of nukes dropped on
civilians and japan didn't have any
anti-ballistic missile system at the
time the idea would be to hit the icbm
and make it blow up somewhere other than
its intended target this with all the
consequences it may have on the
atmosphere anti-ballistic systems are
present in various countries and are
still under full development nowadays
india's abm system is capable of
intercepting missiles up to 2 600
kilometers and potentially to 5 000
kilometers but in a worse scenario no
one has activated their own defense
system yet
in report by the american physical
society panel on the public affairs even
the americans seems to have a limited
capability to intercept an
intercontinental ballistic missile in
the study it is stated the current
capabilities are low and will likely
continue to be low for the next 15 years
to protect the us against a strike from
north korea we are speaking about 20
warheads regarding north korea imagine 6
000 russian nukes goodbye source
proposed by the us administration the
ground-based mid-course defense also
known as gmd is operational in both
alaska and california and provides more
protection against the nuclear threat
from north korean missiles or launches
from russia or china but it's likely
less effective against missiles launched
from the middle east here in italy we
are developing the aster 30 block 2
system with a range of 3 000 kilometers
in the meantime we need to survive
without it and look forward to nato
defense sites one in romania the other
one in poland this means only one thing
boom
detonated a few hundred meters above
piazza del duomo i hope our dr bishop
forgives me the explosion would generate
a ball of fire and hot air of millions
of degrees fahrenheit that would
instantly vaporize everything within a
radius of 880 meters for an area of
about 2 square kilometers the shock wave
will then spread fatally within an area
of 14 square kilometers from the
explosion site severely damaging and
raising most buildings to the ground in
short anyone who manages to survive
within a radius of two kilometers and
380 meters which includes me will have a
short time because the radiation will
prove fatal within a month at four
kilometers and 760 meters the buildings
from the explosion will report moderate
damage but risk of fire will be high
though at a distance of 1 kilometers and
400 meters for a total area of 409
square kilometers so well beyond the
prato up to municipalities such as
sastafiorentino signia campebizencio
poggio cayano and carmignano but not the
much hated city of estoya the hot air
will probably cause you third degree
burns but don't despair you will not
even feel them since it's very likely
that your pain receptor nerves will be
already fatally damaged finally the
explosion will affect a total aerial
477 square kilometers around the
cathedral of prato and depending on
where the wind will blow there will be a
radioactive rain of 181 kilometer which
will affect a different intensity a
total area of 4 000 square kilometer so
if i wanted to save myself at least from
the damage of the explosion i would have
to move at least 12 kilometers from the
center of brato i could be safe in
florence and yes even in the much hated
city of pistoia you know we from prato
have some long lasting disputes with
those in pistolia we don't love each
other very much in case you're luckier
than me you could always live near a
large public fallout shelter the
luckiest ones in italy live in the
province of verona in afi where there's
the largest bunker of its kind in our
country located in the bowels of mount
moscow built in the 60s to house a nato
command post the bunker is thirteen
thousand square meters wide and can
accommodate almost one thousand people
once upon a time it was well stocked but
for some years now it has been
dismantled and it's now almost unusable
you can also try to be lucky entrentino
under mount mice in valdenon where you
will find the gumpen bunker
being bombed during world war ii our
country has hundreds if not thousands of
shelters from private to public ones in
nearby florence you could look for one
of the many city shelters built to
escape from the bombings from the
undergrounds of the basilica of
salorenzo to palazzo vecchio if you
found yourself in florence during a
nuclear attack observe on the walls the
presence of an r indicating the
proximity of a bunker in torino then on
the piazza de rizorgimento there's still
an active shelter capable of
accommodating
1150 people though during the war it
happened to welcome twice as many people
just as in naples where the population
found refuge from bombing in the network
of 19th century tunnels built by the
bourbons famous in milan are shelter 87
under an elementary school
and the breda bunkers in the parkland
north
in rome mussolini and the savoya family
had their own bunkers with blackjack and
hookers today you won't exactly find
this luxury in the bunk around at the
park of villaada once a royal residence
wanted by king vittorio manuela iii you
will find instead an anonymous and
disturbing parking lot however mussolini
had two bunkers one under palazzo
venezia and another one at villa
torlonia both in rome but they were not
even completed
45 kilometers from rome in the meanders
of mount zerate in the proximity of the
town of santoreste you can find a vast
angle of underground tunnels long four
kilometers and designed to accommodate
the highest charges of the army these
tunnels were then partially converted
into a bomb shelter by nato during the
cold war yet if some ill-intentioned
nation wants to attack us we should
expect more than anything else a direct
bombing towards military installations
such as aviano and getty with
consequences that nuke map itself
refuses to consider
i sincerely apologize if i too have
provided you with a daily dose of atomic
anxiety just in case remember your
potassium iodide pills for radiation and
map in your hand to calculate the damage
and the probability of survival a small
advice don't simulate the explosion of
the tar bomb the most powerful ever
built and designed by russia you may
experience nightmares
see you in the next video ciao